une question est dans tous les esprits
pourquoi l'état se désengage pourquoi
alors même qu'il était à l'origine du
projet d'implantation de la marque
mercier dans les ardennes et que le
ministre de la cohésion sociale avait
même fait le déplacement en mars pour
appuyer le projet de réindustrialisation
du site chez les personnes présentes au
rassemblement ce mardi c'est l'amertume
qui prédominent
ici on n'a plus rien et c'est grave
parce qu'en fait il ya des gens ici qui
vont souffrir parce que il aurait cru
avoir beaucoup d'emplois ils n'en auront
pas on est dirigé par des gens qui qui
ne lui prenne pas de responsabilité au
niveau des populations se sont dits
joueurs des pipots il y avait beaucoup
d'emplois que prévu et une maintenance
et tombera à l'eau est ce que c'est le
gouvernement ou les politiques qui peut
se passer on va dire on ne sait pas on
ne sait pas les politiques vont
peut-être leur boulot mais est-ce que ça
c'est la banque publique
d'investissement n'a pas validé le
projet pour des problèmes fiscaux et de
douane une décision qui provoque la
colère du député de la circonscription
je me pose des questions parce qu'au
plus haut niveau de l'état des hauts
fonctionnaires qui sont bardés de
diplômes n'ont pas fait les
vérifications nécessaires donc je
m'interroge vraiment sur l'amateurisme
ce gouvernement mais je crois que la
réponse elle est dans ce dossier au
total six millions d'euros ne seront pas
injecté
qu'importe pour le président de la
communauté de communes l'idée est de
créer des emplois plutôt que de recevoir
de l'argent ce que j'attends c'est un
plan marshall un véritable plan
d'investissement de l'état pour vous
c'est ça qui est ça qui nous faut il ya
quand même des tas d'entreprises qui
veulent s'installer par dpi par business
france etc et de nous trouver de bonnes
entreprises bien crédible pour
s'installer chez nous les habitants de
revin ne croient plus aux promesses
échaudés par plusieurs fermetures
d'usinés de délocalisation et un taux de
chômage à 27% certains préfèrent partir
entre 2013 et 2018 revint a perdu 10% de
sa population